this is bloomberg quick take i'm
scarlett fu
the white house has officially confirmed
that the u.s is staging a diplomatic
boycott against the upcoming 2022 winter
olympics in beijing white house press
secretary jen saki said the athletes of
team usa have quote our full support but
there will be no diplomatic or official
representation at the games so what does
this mean why does it matter let's bring
in dr jules boykov he is professor of
politics and government at pacific
university in oregon he's also author of
four books on the olympic games
including power games a political
history of the olympics professor boykov
thank you so much for speaking with us
so u.s athletes would still be able to
attend and compete in the olympics what
exactly would a diplomatic boycott then
accomplish
so a diplomatic boycott would be a
strong signal to both china and the
international community that the u.s
government will stand up against crimes
against humanity that is what human
rights organizations have been calling
what's happening in xinjiang province at
the moment and so it'll be powerfully
symbolic to stand up against that kind
of thing happening it'll be interesting
to see also whether this
makes other countries join and the
allies of the united states might also
get on board with this so that'll be
interesting to see in the days that come
and to be clear we made a certain that
this is not an athlete boycott
what would turn this into an economic
boycott
well you'd have to have a lot more
economic power to have an economic
boycott of china in general the united
states is incredibly reliant on china
china owns a lot of the u.s debt and so
that would be an entirely different ball
game the reason why they're going with a
diplomatic boycott is because it speaks
against the possibility of sports
washing this is a term we see a lot in
the news these days sports washing is
essentially when a country uses a sports
mega event like the olympics or the
world cup of soccer to try to launder
its reputation on the world stage and by
not sending diplomats to the beijing
olympics that means that the united
states is trying to deprive china of the
possibility of sports washing all those
grin and grip photo ops that are typical
within olympic games won't be happening
at least not with diplomats from the
united states and possibly their allies
okay so it would deprive china of that
photo finish moment where there's lots
of pictures a lot of pageantry because
the people that it wants to impress
simply won't be there attending the
actual games china's take on all this
professor is that beijing apparently had
no plan of inviting u.s politicians to
the games so how can there be a boycott
of an event that they were not invited
to attend
yeah it's going to be really interesting
to follow the back and forth chinese
officials have also said that the united
states doing a diplomatic boycott
violates the spirit of the olympic
charter well a lot of things violate the
spirit of the olympic charter including
carrying out human rights abuses against
your own population so the war of words
will definitely be continuing for the
next couple months in the lead up to the
beijing games right right right you
talked about the crimes against humanity
and other human rights abuses
specifically what we've seen in xinjiang
but none of that is particularly new it
feels in fact like old news simply
because it's been with us for a long
time now
isn't the nba and what's been happening
with the chinese tennis star feng shui
more relevant or at least more immediate
catalysts how much do you think that
played into the us's decision
i think the feng shui situation is
really important in a number of ways
first of all it really raised the
profile of what's happening in china
right now
second of all it was a harbinger
possibly of what could happen to an
athlete should they have the temerity to
speak out against what's happening in
china against any official and maybe
even against the international olympic
committee and the olympics in responding
to the situation with the tennis player
the international olympic committee very
much took the side of chinese
authorities sending a signal to athletes
that in reality when it comes to the
clutch and the prime olympic moment the
international olympic committee might
not have your back as an athlete and so
that would be pretty jarring if you were
thinking about going to beijing as an
olympic athlete and perhaps making a
stand about something that mattered to
you politically the ioc is signaled that
it really doesn't have your back despite
its slogans like athletes come first
when it comes to punctuality they
believe everything that the chinese
authorities have said they haven't asked
for verification they haven't asked for
safe patch out of the country and those
are all big signals to athletes who are
headed to beijing yeah so it's kind of a
warning to any of the olympians who do
go there and and perhaps want to take
advantage of that moment to to really
make clear their point of view on what's
going on in china china has also vowed
to take counter measures we don't know
what that means yet and of course
they've kept it vague the u.s we know
will host the 2028 olympic games in la
would it be too far out for china to say
something about that right
now well it'll be interesting to see
that's one possibility sort of a tit for
tat talking just olympics only but china
has a lot of possibilities at its
disposal you know it's the united states
is quite reliant on china economically
at this point and so we'll see what they
decide to do let's not forget that the
united states is no stranger to
humanitarian crises i'm coming to you
from the west coast of the united states
where homelessness is a humanitarian
crisis in plain sight then there's
guantanamo there's family separation at
the border and so i expect all of those
topics to come into the conversation
when china pushes back against the
government for the united states saying
things to beijing right now yeah
accusing the u.s of crimes against
humanity and human rights abuses there
are plenty of examples there if you
consider what we just discussed now well
we know the olympics are supposed to be
apolitical but come on that's never been
the case from the beginning of time
give us a few of the most recent
examples in which it's clear just how
political the olympics have become
well the olympics were political from
day one when a plucky baron from france
baron pierre to kuberton started the
olympics he brought together powerful
political people from around the world
to create the international olympic
committee he was quite straightforward
about the fact that he needed political
support for his games it's been
political all the way through 1936 when
berlin hosted the olympics and the nazis
created the olympic torch run as a way
of not only getting the olympic spirit
throughout germany but also as a way to
sort of scout out possible invasions
that happen in the wake of those 1936
olympics fast forward to more current
times and look at the 2014 olympics in
sochi where you had
anti-lgbtq laws passed immediately ahead
of those olympics and a lot of athletes
wanting to speak out about that pretty
much every single olympics have
political elements to it and if somebody
tells you otherwise there's a good
chance that they're milking the olympic
machine with both hands meaning they're
making their money off of the olympic
games anybody who looks at the olympics
objectively will see immediately that
they're throwing with the political
that's a great great synopsis there of
the history of how the olympics have
have always been political so looking
ahead professor boykov what do you see
as the next step how else might china
position itself before the 2022 games
well for starters next step we'll see
who joins the united states in a
diplomatic boycott second we have to
keep an eye on whether that eventually
swerves into the possibility of an
athlete boycott that still remains to be
seen that would be a whole different
kettle of two expect that is that likely
i do not believe that is likely i think
a lot of people inside of the olympic
sphere were very much scarred by the
double boycotts of 1980 and 1984. many
of those athletes have been outspoken
and having to live with an asterisk by
their name where it says olympian
asterisk because they didn't actually
get to participate and so i think their
pushback has been so vociferous that i
wouldn't expect an athlete boycott but
hey if things are difficult to predict
we wouldn't have predicted coronavirus
we wouldn't have necessarily predicted a
lot of what's happened in the last
couple of years so anything's really
possible in the next couple months all
right professor jules boykov thank you
so much pacific university professor of
government and politics we'll be
checking in with you as we get closer to
the 2022 olympic games in beijing this
is bloomberg quick take thanks for
joining us
[Music]